Well I was sitting down watching TV and
the neighbor had knocked on the door and
told me I moved your car for you and you
need to get out of here and so I ran to
the door and I saw how high the waters
were and reminded me like the Red Sea of
the water just coming down with full
force and so I turned to Michael my son
and told him you better get out of here
and told his sister we got to go. We didn't
have time to get a coat, a hat, whatever we
had on we had to run honestly and
quickly for our lives. In the midst of that
water, nothing mattered to me: the house didn't
matter, the car didn't matter, it was just life.
I wanted them to be safe. By the goodness of
God, we made it.
Being in high school when all of Sandy was going on
when I had to still be a student, still go to my extra
curricular activities, still had to go to work
and I was considering whether or not I'd still
pursue Harvard, I didn't think of it as
an extra burden. Hurricane Sandy allowed
me to electrify my interest and make it
so that everything that I did meant all
the more. It taught me resilience, it taught me that
you have to press on because people are
counting on you and you should be
counting on yourself.
Michael knew he
wanted to come to harvard at the age of 10
I remember him coming into my room
and he'd say, mommy I figured it out. Harvard's
not too far from here. Annual tuition of
this school is just about as much income
my family has. I learned about the
whole need-based financial aid that
Harvard has, and that basically charged
the rest of my time in high school
the minute I figured out that this
was a thing actually can happen.
I had conceptions of it, this idea that
Harvard people are like sort of snooty
and preppy and stuck up. None of that was
true. The best thing about being here was
the people and the interactions, the
conversations, understanding the world
through others. It is not even
necessarily facilitated that I grow but
it is actually the catalyst of my growth
being here.
I had a leak in my house on
the roof you know when it was an
older house and I said, I need this to get
fixed, so Sandy took out the old and I
believe that if you lose something you
will recover greater things. Every moment
in life counts. Flat out I want to sing I
want to sing, that's plan A. Plan B is
going to law school. It's something I've
always wanted to do. I find law so
intriguing that I feel like that would
be the best medium for me to to give
back to the rest of the world. When I'm
talking to Michael, Michael talks about
his dreams. He thinks ahead, he's a planner.
If there's anything that I learned from
being homeless for 14 months it was that,
you know, you got to find joy and you
gotta find joy in everything. In
everything. I am taking for granted any
moment that I've been given because
nothing short of a blessing that a lot
of people want that not everyone can
have and yeah, I feel like all those
things sort of informed how I existed
Harvard and how I will persist through
time post-Harvard.